you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum hi folks how are ya
what's going on
holy crap man hope everybody had a good
weekend nice and long yeah what'd you do
right well you know this last weekend
that was sick so I couldn't really do
much yeah yeah that sucked man you feel
you're better now I feel better yeah
yeah you kind of look like a bit of a
smack - and you came in because you were
wearing a you know it's it's around
Halloween now so it's the you have you
were wearing the it the Pennywise
costume I was penny wise recently in a
sketch on YouTube yeah sketch on YouTube
but you can check it out where can I
check that out it's on the warp zone
YouTube channel check that out you'll
check out Ryan he's penny wise and he
had to wear these contacts he'd never
worn them hate I hate content I don't
know how you do I I don't know how you
wearing them now and I'm still not used
to them you know a lot of stuff going on
you know the album's been out for about
I don't know about a month maybe and
that's really about it man in love with
Michael Rose moment Chris Sullivan as
you know is airing every Monday so make
sure you subscribe and write a review we
need you today on the podcast we have
drilled Truglio
if you don't know Joe Brooklyn nine-nine
he's amazing he's hilarious I've known
him for a long time there's a couple of
moments here in this podcast that I know
I was transfixed on what he was saying
and so is Ryan it was just really it was
powerful it was it was simple
yeah powerful was applicable to a lot of
things it was applicable to a lot
doesn't matter if you're an actor or
whatever what he says is like sometimes
were jealous of this whether it's a
neighbor or you yeah you know I'm you
know I'm jealous because you know my
buddy Dax has way more followers in it
Delos he's not good you know you're just
like gosh you compare yourself to others
and he has something really to say about
that and it it's really it's it's really
pretty profound you know today it's
pretty interesting the first thing that
he's going to get a colonoscopy tomorrow
so you're hearing him the day before
where he has to not eat anything and you
can tell he's feeling a little
stir-crazy
but you know you've seen him on the
state if you if you're old enough back
in the MTV years ago
Reno 9-1-1 bad this is one of my
favorite guests I say I think I say that
a lot but
really I've known this guy a long time I
just love him and admit I miss him and
it was good having min here I think
you're gonna really dig so let's get in
side of Joe lo Truglio it's my part of
you you're listening to inside of you
with Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
I didn't know what the hell I was doing
in the beginning I was convinced that I
should do a podcast something goes you
got a good voice
you know people yeah have a podcast so I
didn't want to do it and then I did it
thinking okay maybe I can make some
money and then I realized wow it's not
easy to make money in a podcast
hey everybody has a pot yeah what
happened was I probably would have quit
but just one day I just started become
really vulnerable uh-huh really it was
therapy for me because I realized the
way I was living was not honest I mean I
think everybody thought oh he's got his
[ __ ] together he organizes everything
yeah you know he was in a hit show he's
always working he's doing this he got
God the guys always he's so happy well
I'll say this I'll say that already
you're an affable guy you're a friendly
guy you a warm guy and he loved
conversation and you know people I mean
that's those are the type of people that
should be having a podcast you're also
generous and curious to other qualities
yeah for a good podcast so here's to you
on your 19 hey whatever whatever episode
thank you till the Truglio mm-hmm
but it became vulnerable it became like
I felt like I had purpose that's why I
do it I do it because I really love to
talk to people and find out how they get
through they face adversity how did they
get through it
right what do they do what makes them
tick you know people say oh what are you
doing now all you're doing Brooklyn
nine-nine oh you're a big star you but
they don't know your journey and I soar
to know your journey sure I know the
[ __ ] that you went through well I'll say
I'll say this that I don't do a lot of
podcast I often get self-conscious about
it but I also like to see my friends and
I haven't seen you in a while
yeah and isn't that funny like I find
this goes back to the guys at the state
and everything you grow up we get older
they have kids have a family you're like
how can I see more of them how can I see
my friends what if they have a podcast
or we work together and then you're
divorced what I see them I I have to
like it
I just can't meet the majority of I
don't if I don't show up I don't get
paid and I have to see that let's hope
they're a guest star on Brooklyn
nine-nine
it's so convenient for me what am I
gonna do text email give me a break the
only way I always like to see you
haven't seen you in a while yeah and so
I was excited about coming here you know
Matt Fowler journey Matt Balor just
texted me like five minutes before you
showed up
our good friend Matthew Ballard I went
to college with him we got naked at
college we did the cherry run Ballard is
now a family man he's doing really well
he's doing something Rob McElhaney yeah
always sunny great guy great guy that
everybody loves and you guys always all
the guys from the state Showalter and
Marino and holy yeah everybody always
Michael Ian Black all you guys and I'd
noticed like about he became four nine
of you guys yeah I owe money did I meet
you through Ballard I've been not really
so no I think I knew you first maybe I
think you did and and remind me if I'm
wrong it was through MTV were riad MTV
or was it even before MTV it was around
there where you guys were doing the
state what if you guys out there
listening don't know what the state was
look up some old videos find it because
it really all these guys careers like
David Wain Michael Showalter they've
gone on hot what American Tom Marino
Kerri Kenney use a lot and if you don't
know if you're thinking I don't know
those names like no look them up look
those names up and you would holy crap
that guy's hilarious this guy's
hilarious oh my God look what he did
these guys all started together they met
at New York University New York
University
some of us were in film somewhere in
drama but now he old is a trauma us I
meant to say drama but maybe I'll tell
you it's different Queens right that's
why you drama well I'm thinking about
trauma can I tell you I tell you why I'm
the comedy somebody drowned it this is
I'm thinking about trauma right now
because I know this is this is why it's
amazing that I'm doing this podcast
inside tomorrow I'm getting colonoscopy
today I'm in prep I can't I do you
tomorrow dr. Schwartz that's right I get
to to people coming at me now have you
done that yet here's what's also funny
it's just I guess it's because of our
age we just talked about our age but you
know the age just went down two years
ago I went in
- gastro intelligence I can't bounce is
that right I don't know long just saying
it guys it has to ask I yeah and I went
to because my buddy Harlan Williams you
know Harlan yeah you know Harlan's the
if you guys don't know is he's gonna
should the Dumb and Dumber got hey you
guys drinking out of Summa grandpa's
cough medicine are you bug so he said
there's they know I went to the yes guy
and I got a colonoscopy she really do it
I was worried and checked it out for
polyps and stuff I didn't have anything
I'm clean you should probably get so he
has peace of mind I went to see this ass
doctor and I sat down with him he looked
at me goes you know I'm how old are you
and at the time I was like 44 years yeah
you know most guys don't get this till
50 unless there's some things going on
yeah and then all the sudden I read in
Men's Journal or something like a year
ago they've knocked down the age to 45
that's right so now I'm older than that
age yeah so now I'm gonna go get a
colonoscopy there's a few of my friends
that want to go get it we might want to
document it uh-huh
you know go together yeah they take I
don't I don't know I don't know if I but
you know they say the worst part is the
night before when you're just unloading
unleashing yeah that's tonight for me
that's I mean that's a night yes that's
so what do you have to do by the way
this is good for you guys to hear
because it's important so many your
listeners are of this das VH I'm sure
well this is health regardless and get a
husband a boyfriend or you're sure
whatever whatever do this this is Joel
ever leaning up tomorrow what are you
doing tonight to prepare what do you do
all right well today you know it's just
a clear liquid diet guys I get no
breakfast water I could have coffee tea
the the instruction booklet says nothing
red or purple
now do I drink kool-aid no maybe some of
you out there would or popsicles do I
have a lot of red or purple popsicles
during the day I don't have any I can't
remember the last time I had one of
those but I certainly can't have them
today your fluids clear fluids chicken
broth you know some you know beef
bouillon broth how hungry are you right
now not that hungry I don't eat
breakfast that much anyway but I'm glad
this this podcast wasn't it like for
that would have been I would have been
hangry it's gonna be tough later from me
yeah I'm glad we got you I got and when
I got my therapies that's it at five
that'll be interesting right before
I'm ready anything to eat you still know
what's their opinion still no I just I
just kind of started a few months ago
marital problems
it's everything your whole life yeah
it's everything isn't it yeah see how I
just jump in there marital issue says
that I don't know so anyway that's
happening for me tomorrow so tonight all
fluids you go to sleep you wake up oh
you have to take this liquid stuff like
you know right before you go to a four
hour for you go to bed what is that I
don't know but from what I hear from my
friends that have done it it just tastes
terrible and it just makes a [ __ ] I mean
that's you know clears it out clears out
the pipes so you know I kind of have to
stay indoors did people prepare Brian
you're laughing it's just one of it's
funny it's funny this is Ryan by the way
it's my engineer Ryan no it's funny like
you have to stay you can't really go
anywhere and you know a friend of mine
just was gonna have a screening tonight
and I'm like I want to go and he's like
actually you know we may have some it's
pretty tight you you really want to go I
really do but it might be good that I
don't because dot dot dot so yeah
there's this thing there's a lot of
reasons one I have to have the very back
row aisle one if you can't get me that
seat I'm not coming yeah yeah we're
going oh yeah that's right that it's
important I kid I didn't want I didn't
want to put that pressure on him Ryan's
too young Ryan here is how old are you
31 if 30 wants to know this right now
right yeah I got some time you get
prostate exams Ryan no have you ever had
a finger in your buns well that's
different
you have had that no you haven't have
you Joe sure I've only had one in my
life and I have this conversation with a
lot of people oh because a lot of guys
will tell me they have fingers in the
process to the prostate exams and I
don't know no my doctor says it's
unnecessary now you could just do a
blood test check your PSA and you're
fine
but I'm hearing back and forth things
like that so I actually went to my
doctor I said look I'm a little like I
don't know sensitive about this so yeah
you did not put a finger in my ass yeah
that's 20 years I've known you I don't
like we've known each other a long time
how come no finger and then he goes do
you want one I go not if I don't if you
really don't think I need one if you
don't need one is it that bad I had one
right before I had back surgery once and
there was no need because I'm like I'm
having backs
not a surgery right so the guy says mr.
Rosenbaum are gonna you know I this is
protocol so if you could bend over you
know I want you to know that don't be
embarrassed
some men some men not old men but they
occasionally ejaculate and I and I told
him if this happens I'm gonna jump eight
stories to my death out the window this
of shame of shaming embarrass could you
imagine you're there as a straight guy
or a gay guy yeah and this old guy puts
a finger in your button you unload in
this cold hospital floor a big tough
it's just not personal it's not a
personal intimate moment then you want
to have that you want to remember really
you know yeah you want something with a
little bit more ambience yeah tomorrow
tomorrow do they do they you wake up in
what time's your procedure I think it's
around one and I gotta be around 12:30
I'm going under the gas oh yeah all they
get is a gas or Canadian or short you
wonder you want gas or you could take or
you can take out the heavy-duty truck
you don't like that well you know it's
not that but I'm told that where I was
warned that you might not feel pain but
feel something and I don't want to feel
anything I don't need to remember this
just like going there tell me what's got
talking what's up and I'll wake up and
then you tell me and and so and so I'm
gonna go with the anesthesia are you
going Caesar so you can go anesthesia or
gas we don't know the gas being the
anesthesia or like like like you know
opioids like oh god it's the day just
like intravenous I wanna be out I want
to be out out I want to wake up and go
you weren't in my ass yeah I don't think
you were you can't prove it yeah yeah
there's yeah there's yeah show me
pictures
no I oh there they are oh yeah yeah yeah
you were there okay fine you know you
nervous a little bit
I shouldn't be I never used to be
nervous about stuff like this and I'm
not really very nervous but I had
surgery before like adenoids out tonsils
and as a kid and needles don't scare me
but like I don't know if it's you get
older you have more to lose you're
enjoying life more a kid yeah I have a
kid
Eli Eli after Eli Manning stop it no
you're a Jets fan oh yeah yes so we're
not even talk about that
right now I almost almost we almost
named his middle name jet because of
that thank God we didn't that would just
would well you could have told people
was after a wing song well the thing
will wing some jet uh oh that oh okay
yeah that's true yeah well you know we
decided that at the end of the day when
I hear the name Eli
I'll probably still think of my kid and
not Eli Manning see before the kid comes
here Eli
I think of Eli Manning but now that
Eli's here I'm gonna think of my son
right
so that was quickly that fear was
quickly washed away right all right look
we've talked about apps for the first
ten minutes of the show I mean mm-hmm
look I've known you for a long time we
talked about the state I remember those
days when you were always so humble so
fun to be around
I just felt comfortable around you just
a genuine guy you've always been so
genuine and I always said you know I
always thought kind of I want that guy
to keep you know nice doing well because
you are you're just a genuinely good
dude and you're so funny and I remember
watching the state and going god this
guy's so funny you just gotta understood
and I remember you struggle we all
struggle but like yeah for years right
your way people think oh Brooklyn
nine-nine he did
Reno 909 one yeah you know it's kind of
hard to say Reno 911 nine-nine I play a
lot I played a lot of cops one that's
really nice of you to say
Mike and it's the you know the struggle
is real for a lot of people for many of
us actors but I try to surround myself
with good people I was the first step
and and try not to take it too seriously
but it you know it was nice to have the
success I had but you know there's some
bitterness there there was some
comparing myself and some jealousies
along the way that you have to kind of
you know eat up you know did you ever
resent like in the beginning don't
thinking you know one of your buddies
your peers I think we've all gone
through it is like I was doing so well
it's like why can't he just give me a
lift
why can't he just [ __ ] why can he
drop me off the 23rd and fourth you know
he's give me a ride
you know just give me a lift I don't
know a nice series but something yeah
right I mean you there's no way like I
have friends that you know when I was in
Smallville or in pastor you know I was
filming in Canada so they would hire all
Canadian locals and you know sometimes
I'd have people audition or something I
didn't have that choice like it's not
like you know I'm pastor finally was a
thing where I was an executive producer
I was like hey I want my friend whoever
to come home I want my friend Troy to do
that so my friend Roger to come on I
wanna if there's a role I want them even
if it's not that big I want them to be a
part of that I would do if I ever had if
I was ever a creator producer of a show
I mean these are things I'm trying to do
but that's that's when you give back you
know I I think that's great that you did
that you have to do that yeah but you
know I haven't been I've been a creator
of things that haven't aired so or have
not even been shot just I sold something
so that's exact you know when I did my
movie yeah I remember I did directed
this movie back in the day and it was
just like a raunchy lowbrow fun comedy
and I was like Balor get up you know you
find out Sarah Gillard flying out
Josephina you're flying out whatever I
could do my friend Jay Ferguson is on
Mad Men oh he already had a career but
I'm like please do this role anybody any
of my friends I just wanted to be in the
it's so satisfying isn't it if you see
like we years I made five years ago me
and Michael Ian Black created this show
called beef which was like Judge Judy
meets like The Sopranos and the bit is
it takes place at like a butcher shop
and and you know the the guy forgetting
characters name but Chris Meloni played
him would set all these neighborhood you
know in skirmishes like yeah I went over
with nice craft beer over to Johnny's
like Super Bowl party and then you know
he wouldn't let me have that he hid the
beer we had to drink his like Bud Light
[ __ ] and you know I feel then he kept of
crap beer you know stuff like that right
so and and I invite Bauer did some and a
lot of my friends that you know are so
good so talented but just haven't gotten
you know that chance yet it felt awesome
like in and I feel that's important I
think you gotta look out I think it I
think it is important and it's also hard
when you don't have a lot of the you
know especially like when I was in
smaller than I had a lot of success I
just remember going I know what they
want they want these pretty boys yeah
pretty girls
show and they have to be Canadian they
can't afford it because you know they're
cheap and they you know unless it was
like it just was like you know and
you're like you're on a hit show dude
why can't you get me on Smallville it's
like if you look at it
everybody was young except for me yeah
like everybody's young and there's my
dad Lionel Luthor and yeah but there
wasn't a lot I could do I did try you
weren't a producer on we're you know
what's gonna produce sir you didn't have
that let a lot of it is this kind of
misunderstanding of how the business
works and how the power you know
structure works in the hierarchy and
just like oh you're on Brooklyn I know
just like put me on a like believe me on
how or I mention you to jewel best rep
who was fantastic kasi misra me to her I
have not mentioned you that I thought
you were talking awkward that you asked
me that now this is we're sorry Joe fine
all right Rosie I'll talk to her oh so
many ways how does he do it how did he
do it but yeah but like you know you
have to go through these certain
channels and I do I do and by the way do
you want to come on the show would I
come on Brooklyn I'd yeah you mean a hit
show that you're on that's not love I
don't know I do it yeah some people are
very selective and I am so in terms of
like I just don't like it why people go
what are you doing I go you know what I
just want to do my own stuff and I wanna
I won't unless it's like obviously if
it's something that I just you know
Jensen Ackles he's a lead on
supernatural okay and he emailed me last
night he's like dude call your [ __ ]
agent and get on supernatural tour last
season and I'm like yeah and it's so
nice because this is huge so huge phony
Inc million people and I'm like you know
in my head I'm like I love Jensen and I
love you know love the show I love my
love supernatural [ __ ] and I love the
fans and the fans are good so I'm like
you know if it's the right thing um I I
would do it of course are you kidding me
I'd be lucky bum but yes it's like we'd
be lucky to have you so dude I'm gonna
phone your name out to make kidding me I
love it even if it was like something
fun and quick I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't I mean you go with that stuff just
becoming to be funny
egos are tough to keep in check are
intended I've been learning about a you
go I've learned I've really you know
I've talked about this but you don't
know this but I went off to a Wellness
Center for three weeks
well I listened to some of your
so I must rly I do but not a lot we were
talking about meditation I just started
that a few months ago as well but you do
it every day I do it every day for 10
minutes
I've missed you know sometimes I miss a
day or two but it's been it's been very
very helpful how do you feel when you
miss a day guilty yeah isn't that
something it's like it's like a routine
thing it's like yeah I try to express it
to people but if you're doing something
like everybody do I wake up I drink four
cups of coffee oh I wake up I have a
cigarette
oh I wake up I do this I go now imagine
that you feel like you have to do that
imagine you break that routine you don't
realize that you know you quit a habit
takes 21 days imagine a new habit and
now you're going that's what happens
it's like I hate meditation I hate
meditation and then two weeks and I'm
like I have to keep doing that yeah and
now it's today is 96 days straight
I wake up and I do 20 minutes and I
cannot miss it or I feel like a failure
and that's a good routine now even if
people think oh well I don't know how my
mind's racing like [ __ ] look at
me yeah it's fine you say that because
that was an intimidating thing for me
starting meditations well because like
how you meditate what do you intensity I
got everything's got to be quiet no and
then you know he's working with Zappos
listen to this app they're gonna say
you're listening to Zach Galifianakis
elephan a kisses meditation tape and
it's wonderful it's wonderful I'm gonna
let you finish it you got a finished
happen I really want to do he knows this
I want to do a meditation app I want to
do my voice yeah
like because but I want to like you talk
about what I'm thinking yeah like I it
would be [ __ ] like this Joe I want to
hear yours too I would be like all right
listen if you're like me you know your
mind is going nuts right now
I should take a piss before this thing I
should probably uh I don't know wash my
face I should brush my teeth my breath
is so bad right now but listen listen
nothing matters right now no one's
smelling your breath I want you to just
it was it's not clear so that's why
you're hearing that you know that's a
cat raka in the distance I listen to
that but it's just like how are you home
so I would be like I am thinking those
things this guy know that what would
yours be I do well I think might they're
all it's always deep right but it would
be let's sit down let's find a
comfortable place let's concentrate on
what it feels like to think about what
you're gonna do later wait don't do that
breathe did you make plans to have lunch
don't think that either they keep
sabotaging the meditation a little bit
[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by calm
at sea ALM calm I just feel calm saying
it Ryan saying the word calm
yeah I'm neurotic a little a DDM all
over the place I need a break
okay and I needed number one app for
sleep and relaxation period okay I need
to transform my nights which means
better days
okay Ryan calm does that calm has
bedtime stories for adults you could
hear them narrated by iconic voices like
levar burton nick offerman it includes
hundreds of sleep stories and a ton of
other content like soothing music from
artists like sam smith guided
meditations I love the guided
meditations I when you're doing it alone
what happens your mind races so why not
have someone guide you like
breathe in through your nose exhale
everything's calm you see how that works
I've already come I'm telling you man
breathing exercises I tell people all
the time how important meditation how
important relaxation and this app is
it's there's no secret I don't even know
why I'm trying to sell it cuz it sells
itself it's the number one app for sleep
and relaxation it transforms your nights
and it makes the days better for a
limited time our show listeners can get
25% off a comprar Miam subscription at
com.com promo code ryan i owe you
that's calm calm / I owe you
it comes with unlimited access to comes
entire library a new content is added
every week get started today at calm
calm / I owe you inside of you is
brought to you by embark I got this
embark dog DNA test kit which is by the
way the most comprehensive kit in the
market you got to know what your dog is
because I mean it's just you're doing
your dog injustice if you don't find out
what buried it is because you could
study their behavior it helps you learn
their behavior certain breeds training
for a better quality of life know your
dog's breed to learn how to best care
for your pump I did mine and you know I
always thought curve was just like is
price Shepard I don't know Australian
Kelpie he looks like a kelpy Ryan look
at this result genetic breed result for
ERV 43.8% German Shepherd so hey I was
right there yeah I thought it was gonna
be like eighty seventeen point nine
percent American Pitbull Terrier oh oh
ten point four percent Chow Chow 10.2%
Labrador Retriever almost 10% collie and
seven point nine percent
super month it's just cool to know that
isn't it about your dog he's a regular
little melting pot wouldn't you want to
know Ryan where your where your kid was
from well my kid was oh my oh my dog is
your child let's say let's say you
adopted a child you know that's the
first thing I where is the child from
anywhere embark best in
dog DNA test number one highest rated by
customers developed by pH DS plus
veterinarians for your dog 100 times
more genetic information captured makes
embark the most accurate and the only
one in the market who can make
scientific discoveries toward improving
the health of your dogs I don't know why
you don't have this I have it
I mean sure there my sponsor and they
gave it to me but I loved it and now I'm
looking at all this great stuff about
Irv and I could help him live the
healthiest happiest life and he doesn't
have many years left Embarq has an
exclusive holiday offer that you can't
get anywhere else go to embark vet
dot-com now that's embark vet dot-com
now and use promo code inside to save
15% off your dog DNA test kit visit him
bark vet calm and use promo code inside
to save embark so we talked about your
journey when you're doing the state I
mean this is MTV back in what year this
was 90 90 to 92 we did a show called you
wrote it you watch it which we were
re-enacting letters about from from fans
and we were doing that show that wasn't
our show we were one of the directors on
there and then that was 92 losing all
tract I think 93 is when we started the
state yeah because I think I did the
pilot for that show that never made it
like in 95 or 96 so that's probably
around the - 95 we did the CBS disaster
you know they see when we jump to the
network and then that was that was I
cocked over 95
so the mem TV show is like before then
so what was it like I mean you're
getting New York University meeting all
these guys these big personalities was
there an immediate attraction immediate
love between all of you where you were
just like you all thought each other and
you liked everybody yeah there was at a
we we took each other pretty quickly and
I don't know it's one of those things
where you you never know why this group
of people got together I think we were
all very smart ambitious extremely
talented those guys are incredibly
talented and and so I feel like that you
know people like that attract each other
and there was safety in numbers there's
like okay what if we came up with you
know at the you know a group where we
can all perform and write and so it
happened pretty quickly
in terms of us getting along of course
as you move on there's dysfunction in
any big group and you know those
dynamics start to get particular and and
everyone sees what annoys each other
about each other and so who was a leader
though was there a leader with what it
was a David well no no the the the our
friend Todd Holoubek founded the group
Todd Holoubek was in a sketch group with
David Wain and Mo Willems you know who
Mo Willems I don't Mo Willems is an
incredible and very popular children's
book author and he had founded this
sketch group called the sterile yak the
Todd Holoubek and David Wain were and
Todd broke off from that and formed a
group called the new group which ended
up becoming the state so that was that's
then this is all at NYU now who did you
think honestly in the beginning when you
first were there and Mike in school you
like this guy is the funniest who did
you look up to were you like oh I mean
not to say look this is then so it's not
like you're saying putting throwing
anybody under the road
yeah yeah was it that your god this
guy's gonna be a star Wow well you know
ken was like that ken made me laugh very
hard Marino Tomlin was wicked smart and
funny although it's funny Tom Lennon and
we talked about this so I don't feel bad
sharing this like I didn't like Tom when
I first met him tom was very tom had it
Tom Tom seemed very like arrogant to me
and standoffish and we ended up going in
for this student film directed by Adam
Marcus who did one of the Jason movies
and we were in the audition and we just
hit it off we had a great audition we
booked this student film and we've been
close ever since I love that man he's
generous abut it's interesting right how
you meet somebody and like you don't
take to them immediately and then they
become really really close do you have
you have friends like that yeah I also
think it's it's easy for people I don't
know how many times someone is you know
said either about me or about a friend
of mine or somebody I know or an actor
and now I've learned not to listen
they're like yeah my friend Joan her
friend John his friend Jim said that Dax
Shepard was not really nice and I'm like
why
I'm by the way this isn't a true story
this is not a truce no it's not a true
story but like you know and like why I
don't know she said she went up to him
to get a picture and he'd want to take a
picture I'm like do you think maybe he
might have had been having a bad day you
think maybe he was in a rush was he
eating was yeah you know I'm a good
judge of character I think that's a good
trait of mine for the most part I meet
people in like this person's good I
trust them they seem like a genuine
person I my friends are better than me
yeah I was part but I I give people the
benefit of death they say so and so I go
you know that's well that's why you have
so many friends I mean you what's
amazing about you Rosie is that I want
you your Halloween party I don't know
when it was a few years ago in October
it was it last year I was at that
meeting listen in my other Zico Matthew
another terrific chiropractor we were a
bunch of boneheads showing up like not
in costume everyone's in costume and so
I think I wore like a Quint shirt or
some JA shirt anyway you have so many
people that love you you should know
that you should know that because it's
important and it's easy to forget things
like that especially when you're feeling
I don't know alone or out of it not in
sync not feeling I could pull on like I
went there I'm like look at all these
guys Rosie that's amazing and it's true
and I and I was happy to be there and to
be invited and that I also knew you so
it just the whole bond of that known
that because that's it's an important
thing to remember when you when you have
those days where you like what the [ __ ]
am I doing again but you know how this I
want to say first of all I genuinely
thank you for that I think it's
incredibly kind of you and I appreciate
that the problem my mind it's not that I
don't believe you it's not that I don't
think they love me my friends love me
it's this dichotomy of yeah of course
but then I'm always organizing stuff and
doing fun things and doing this and
having Thanksgiving and having a
Halloween party and doing what if I just
didn't do that anymore well they still
want to give a [ __ ] about me right still
love me and I would hope the answer is
yeah I think some of them for sure I'm
just like sometimes I want I worry I go
god you're such a helper you're such a
people please or you're such like I want
to be liked you know and it's you know
it's kind of like dude for y'all wanna
be like true but like you don't you have
your family you have your job you have
your
kid you don't go hey I'm gonna do this
and invite all these people all the time
and right and I am getting better at it
and I've been working on myself but you
know and I genuinely think people care
about me yeah I do
it's not about that's not it's hard for
me to allow people in I think I think I
just you know I've talked about this a
billion times but you know getting it at
a young age getting getting on life em
you walk around life you know like I
don't know if I've ever been really felt
loved yeah that I was really like loved
few people I feel that way but I can
relate to that I related that yeah I can
relate to that in that there are many
times when I'm in a room and I'm like
what the hell am I doing here with all
these amazing people like what what
what's that about I should not be here
and I've realized that you're never in a
room you're not supposed to be in if
you're in the room you deserve to be in
the room period so that's helped me just
take it step right at brac take a step
right mama drama yeah but what else is
app this is what happens when you when
you prep for a colonoscopy II just yeah
protein in your mind right you're a
begging you to get rid of [ __ ] yes but
like you have to step back and and
remember that you're there for a reason
to just accept it just own it you know
and that's helped me I hear your point
too about having a family right if I you
know have this amazing place that you
have with all these incredible things
that inspire you in it that's wonderful
and yet you're like well what what else
is there what what about family all that
stuff like I could understand where your
where your head might start to spin and
be like what happens if I don't throw
the party so is it just do I turn into
Howard Hughes or or whatever it is you
know what I mean but you won't man you
won't you won't there's too many you you
you are you're a people gather you have
an energy to you that just people like
it so don't sweat it well I thank you my
friend
yeah man my friend but look back to you
back to me side of you what's it's it is
inside of me what else do we what we
haven't talked about uh why don't we
talked about what Brooklyn well I don't
want to talk about Brooklyn but you know
that whole journey from going
from the state into this like you know
starring on things Oh doing things you
always like going hey you know I
remember playing poker with you I
remember being at bars with you yeah and
it's just like hey Joe what are you
doing I know when I might do this
independent thing I don't know yeah pain
I remember going up to your quadruple
banger it's called its fourth you know
you're staying in this thing one of
those little private urinals yeah you
know those and you were just like yeah
I'm doing this little bit part I've
waited 14 hours I haven't shot yet and I
can just tell like you know you didn't
you didn't show up but I knew it like
you're like I just I just want something
the hit yeah you know I just want to be
able to go on set every day yeah and be
have a purpose yeah say I'm here to do
my part and and work you wanted a war
you're starting you're sorry this is a
very interesting part of the
conversation which segwaying into now
because what you're talking about is
accepting when your time is right I had
a long time accepting when my time was
going to be many actors go through that
Mark Kevin Jackson just did a podcast
with Brooklyn nine-nine and I was
talking about Brooklyn nine-nine in that
I almost didn't go in for Brooklyn
nine-nine
I almost didn't get Brooklyn nine-nine
because I'd gone and I put myself on
tape for Alison Jones then they wanted
me to come back in for a callback or a
session at that point I was during a
very kind of dark time in my career in
my head about my career like you know
what I've done
super bad I've done all these like
little movies like enough is enough
like everyone knows what I can do like
cast me or don't cast me but like I'm
tired of it I was really the ego was all
overwhelming swallowing me up and so I
almost didn't go and if I didn't go
I wouldn't up be on the show clearly
more importantly the lesson learned is
that no one owes you anything and if
you're doing a job because you're
expecting to get another job you gotta
find what you like about it I know
that's you hear it all the time you
finally join what you do but the older
to get you realize that's really the
truth because it put me in such a a mood
of I know this and people know what I
can do and just give it to me give it to
me entitlement that it really starts to
weigh you down and it starts to
infiltrate you in negative ways and you
don't enjoy where you're around I
remember
Camerino it's why he's such a great guy
his wife Erica Yama brought this thing
really funny digital series called
burning love that Ken was in of so many
funny people were in that and I was
shooting that and I was just in a
terrible mood and like Ken how to bring
me insight like while we're shooting you
know I didn't know disruption during the
set but between takes I was just like
not the greatest of moods and he's like
what's up man he's like man
so can I love you I love this this is so
funny like I just gonna be doing this
like web shows like it was really
narrow-minded ungrateful type of stuff
and he heard me as a friend and he
related and Here I am talking to someone
that also hadn't got his big but Ken's
amazing it's in all this stuff but also
hadn't gotten his break and you've
realized you just end up sounding like a
complete [ __ ] because you can't see
your path you can't see when is your
time and it took me a while and if I had
kept in that kind of mode well then I
don't get Brooklyn nine-nine and now
Brooklyn nine-nine has given me a gift
that is above and beyond I mean I have a
new family I've gone through life
changes several of us have gotten
married several of us have gotten have
had kids including myself if I had like
nah [ __ ] it I'm not going in that is not
open to me anymore
that's not here and that's a very
humbling place to be when you're like
now I'm getting it
this struggle is real even after you
think you've made the big time not the
big time but like super bad it is super
bad I'm like that movie was huge I'm
like oh well here we go it's the only a
matter of time now start getting the
calls here they come they don't come you
know you still have to go in you suck to
do all that stuff so you just have to
keep it in check because no one owes you
anything no one's gonna give you the
money for the movie no one's gonna write
the script for you no one's going to
like create the ideal part for you you
find it you get it or just follow or if
you don't know how to get it follow the
things that are coming at you that are
opening up to you and maybe that will
lead you there I know there was a there
was a lot of that stuff going on for me
about seven years ago I don't think I've
ever listened that hard
life Ryan I noticed you too I noticed
there's an energy shift what you just
said was worth the whole podcast and
worth it to me and I know worth it to
Ryan because that [ __ ] right there
is is so vital into whether you're an
actor or not it's it's it's whether
you're an astronaut or it isn't
you're right when you're the ego gets in
the way
the ego my [ __ ] egos got in the way
of so many things where I'm like even on
this I'll even talk about this podcast
like now in the beginning was like I
don't know what I'm doing I don't sound
the good I don't hear my voice I never
listen to my voice yeah but I've gotten
so many responses and people's lives
have changed and it gives me purpose and
I love it
Dax get so many more listeners than I do
okay I start comparing you start
comparing her since hard why does he
well he's a bigger star than you that's
why he gets bigger listeners I know but
he got the idea from what the iPod but
he also but so but he's great and for
some reason he's got a bigger audience
than you if so what and then I'm like I
know no I love it I love him he deserves
that well I'm dad she's one of my best
friends but I'm I guess it's kind of
jealous I'm like God it is I'm gonna be
honest I
I wish I god I love my podcast I think I
do a really good job I think people
enjoy it I I want more listeners you
know what you know what there's you know
the lesson I learned was play as soon as
you realize that there's abundance
you'll be all right with that there's
room really for everybody everybody so
Dax absolutely deserves that chorus at
podcasts he's great at it and you're
great at this so there's just room for
everybody I mean that's just a bigger
lesson and borrow singing from him sure
can I just say that Wrentham I'll just
give me five cent of your audience a 5%
of Dax's audience come over here because
come on over because by the way my fans
are so loyal and they're the listeners
are so low and even like Jen from
legendary films so I met with about some
projects weeks ago I got an email from
her today saying I love the podcast I
listen to it it's so good and I'm like
oh my god
so people are listening and I love it
I'm not gonna stop I don't care if it's
like nobody as long as one person's
listening whoever you are out there I
really love doing it so right whether I
make a lot of money or no money or
whatever I am going to get
you need to do this because I really
love talking to people like you can tell
you could tell I just like it I'd like
to do this my whole life
how great is it you know to have an
intimate conversation with interesting
people some of which you have a history
like myself others you met for the first
time it's the best you said something
remind me of another story about
comparison and jealousy it's I guess 90
oh no it's actually far than that's in
like 2000 the state is is long done I
have been doing like commercials here
and there you know maybe an independent
film or here some voice over nothing
very exciting and yet I see all my state
can Patriots kind of doing their working
working yeah I get this audition for a
movie it's Artie Lange's beer league I
am in the audition the casting director
and I I won't name ur name it says okay
I'm gonna you're gonna slate and then
we're gonna you can slate your name I'm
going to ask you some questions and then
we're gonna go into the the scene and by
the way don't there's no improv and they
really you know stick to the script I'm
like oh yeah all right sure
so hi Joe lo Truglio yeah Joe and so you
were a member of the state uh-huh member
states gets comedy met at NYU and so so
many of your compatriots are like
working at Reno 911 did what hada and
everyone seems to be like working except
for you that's Slade is running by the
way the cameras on me I was that all
about
I'm like well you know I'm just trying
to do my thing you know literally inside
I'm like ready I'm I can't believe I'm
furious like this ego and the comparison
it's just coming at me full force now
because of this question and I just
decided well you know I'm just doing my
thing and in my head I decided oh I'm
gonna be improv it now there's there's
no sticking to the script now I ended up
booking the part and it was it was it
was a really good feeling knowing that
when you're up against it and the
throwing you know egg on your face and
they're just really kind of beating you
just stand up come come at him come at
him now in her defense I don't think she
meant to
make me feel that way I don't know she
just wasn't a good interview I don't
think she was a good interviewer and I
don't know were very aware of the
terrible insecurities of actors and the
level of comparison that goes on with us
every minute of the day so I don't I
don't I don't I don't you know I'm
painting her as a terrible person she's
not I'm sure but that was a terrible
moment for me that I came out and I rose
out of the ashes Phoenix that the
Phoenix do you think that do you think
that doctors look at other doctors and
go I'm just as good of a doctor as him
whatever there's many patients yeah how
how much is he making oh my god I want
too many heart surgeries they did Ron do
I want the University of Pittsburgh
where do you go DeVry oh I mean I could
went to st. John's I mean I think
everybody does it though don't they yeah
I think every Kerr everybody yeah
whether you're driving a UPS truck
it's same thing it's like dude he's
making more than me I'd bust my ass they
work twice as hard as he is comparison
jealousy they are just monsters man but
you know what look I still get it I'm
just able to be like right that's what
I'm feeling now you still get it right
you let it let it let you know that it's
gonna dissipate jealousy right yeah you
know what I I'm it's getting less and
less it really it truly it's evaporating
because I'm I'm really going what does
it matter what is it cuz honestly feel
like you're probably in the right place
right now I'm getting there because I
really feel like when I'm 80 yeah and I
die what is all these things matter what
is what is the house matter and and jobs
that I've done what matters is the
memories and the friendships and the
things that I the enjoyment of life yeah
the taking and living not going through
the motions not trying to compare not
trying to be someone but being the best
you can be being the best human you
could be giving and trying to love and
that's those are the things I'm working
on so when my agent gets mad and says
dude you know you do want to work again
do you want to like I'm like I am
writing a horror script right now I'm
I'm pitching the script that I wrote for
TV I'm doing an animated series with my
friend Harland I am doing two podcasts
this is what I want to do but that's not
where the big bread-and-butter money
from I go you know what a Spielberg
calls you let me know we all answer that
[ __ ] call yeah I'm lucky by the way
this isn't like look dude I've said this
if I am like broke and someone goes well
yes I'll do anything
I don't care what it is I worked at
Burger King to make money I don't care
that's how my whole mentality was work
work work work work but then I got to a
point where look I'm not [ __ ] I don't
have like a Brooklyn nine-nine who knows
what the [ __ ] I'm just saying I don't
have the kind of money where I could
just I can be I'm comfortable right now
I'm comfortable that I don't have to
just I have to work I see we have some
[ __ ] you money right I don't know how
much [ __ ] you yeah it's more than that
yeah that for me for me you know many
goals for a career but for me is to its
right Brooklyn nine-nine is just amazing
you know is to have a great job
obviously and and with people that you
love but you know you don't have control
over that
ideally I'd love to have a nice savings
of money so like if jobs how long that I
really don't want to do I can say no
yeah I want to work on this movie I mean
I I think for many actors many many
people in the in the creative arts I
think have that goal that's realistic no
one wants to do anything they don't want
to do I think part of the reason maybe
it's easier for the jealousy to go away
now it's like well you know what I'm
like in your twenty you don't know
anyway everything is possible you don't
know what you want to do and you see
people doing all that looks cool that
looks cool that looks great I don't do
that I want to do that and you get older
and you're like oh I actually want to do
this and I'm doing it you know I'm
writing my movie or what and it makes it
easier and you're not comparing yeah you
know I also think that after the right
place after 25 years of you know
whatever I'm 47 there has to come a
moment where you go oh that's not
working for me
yeah also by the way and the bigger
thing doesn't work by the way
we're all dust alright that's what I was
trying to say we're all dust that's what
I was trying in the wind yeah
in the wind we're all Kansas lovers
that's what I was saying you said it
more frankly more compact we're all
that's what so what does it matter you
know what makes me feel better
pizza-making
one else feel good maybe you know I
think we're all put on this earth maybe
to just make other people happy which
will make us happy if we're making other
people happy with if we're helping other
people that's making us feel good if
you're doing something that contributes
to society of humanity whatever it is
and I think for a lot of my life it was
me me me me me me me me show show
voiceover travel friends this there
wasn't that connection
and now just working with hands on in
charities and working with people and
trying to help people and going
somewhere for four hours to and and
leaving going it might have helped
someone today oh yeah I did that's
that's me I swear it Alma actually makes
me tear up a little because so food on
foot is a nonprofit organization that
I'm a part of it's for homeless people
and they are high functioning homeless
people so a lot of times people get
money from the government that are
mentally ill and things but the people
that are actually high-functioning that
could work and they could do those are
the people that suffer so they don't get
the money so a lot of times you see
these people on Sundays when you're
feeding the homeless and you're doing
these things and then this organization
is great because it says if you're
motivated if you want to be if you want
have a job if you want to have a place
to live you can yeah and that's what the
organization's about we're gonna help
you do that but you have to show us
that's great you're motivated so just
Sunday this guy Eric graduated the
program and I'm just there I'm you know
and we're all there's a hundred and some
people there and people come there just
to say oh I fed the homeless today and
that's nice they showed up whatever
doesn't matter you're there you're there
and they he starts giving his speech
about you saying hey man you know and he
was very humble and he's just like you
know telling about this is where I was
and what this organization did and I
just I was just lost in that and in my
heart that's so great and I and I
honestly had to back up because I didn't
want all these people to see me kind of
crying yeah so I just backed up and I
just and that feeling is worth so much
more than most of the [ __ ] feelings
that you get that aren't even real any
anything anything to stop thinking about
yourself is a good thing I think I mean
you know that's a good lesson remember
like I gotta get it off of me it's just
do you feel like a whole weight is off
you I you're like and then like what you
saying you see this change that you're
making and other people it says let her
been talking about this at I think after
his heart attack he was talking about
like just how great it is to like help
people like it's really true like like
for instance my amazing wife Beth Dover
is at the Federal Building right now
bonding an immigrant out of jail so he
can get with his family you know she's
with this organization called immigrant
families together that will make a huge
difference to a person
I mean she's incredible for many many
reasons but that is only one of many
things I love about her but that feeling
is like unn comparable to anything like
can you imagine you're gonna have a
picture of a man that it gets to go back
to his three kids and his wife that are
here in San Antonio that he was gonna
get to I mean this is the real stuff
like it's better than like an audition
that you're gonna miss or an episode of
Brooklyn nine-nine you know it's it's
real it's it's real the struggles real
you know and it's it's good to remember
stuff like that I need to do more of it
I think everyone needs to do more of it
I think if everybody just took one day
out of the week to do something just to
go go to a old-age home go to accomplice
don't go to a homeless shelter join food
on foot join me in a Sunday go to a
Ronald McDonald House help echoes of
Hope with foster youth anything a day
and you spent three hours and you're
gonna go what am i doing I worry about
me all the time all the time and this is
just taking a moment you'll be surprised
surprised at how good you feel like it
is like oh my god is it how do I know
he'll think of this yeah helping other
people hey do you still do stress do you
still on set to you do you when you're
learning your lines no no are you
stressed at all anymore
you know your stuff yeah you are excited
about work you don't ever go oh my god
I'm [ __ ] up I can't do this know that
no and has that have her happened oh of
course
of course I think early in the beginning
you don't want to [ __ ] up and you don't
want to you think you're not good enough
for you you're trying to get your your
your sea legs on whatever new production
you're on but
I've been doing this since oh wow and I
and I love that I've been doing it so
long that it is second nature I remember
there was a time where I used to work
for like an hour every night I just
don't have the time to do that anymore
like oh like and I do stuff now like
morning of like makeup trail look at
sides and start like learning them and
start thinking of basically lines on the
day of yeah yeah because it's more
improvisational feeling no because it's
just like such a tool now like like it's
seven years like you know TV you get
used to like how much time you'll have
between shots and like you you know you
have time to really look at it you also
know your writers you know the language
of the script you know that they know
they're writing for your character so
it's easy for you to think that like
that character and therefore remember it
easier yeah so it's so real you know
you're not thrown like if I'm look if I
get a job tomorrow where I'm playing
this like dramatic role if I speed or
verbiage or even out of speech but
longer lines that have different rhythms
you'll work on I need to work on that
like I Charles Boyle is like you know
back of my hand
you know I in a great way and so I don't
stress out about how to do Boyle anymore
you know so it's normal for me like when
I'm doing a role or its dramatic or
whatever that I really take a couple of
days to learn those lines that I have to
know they're not just like a line here
three lines here I'm you know if you
want to be big chunks of scene you have
speeches and things like that
I can't I've never been one to wake up
go to work look in the trail and go oh
here we go and yeah I got it I know
those people you Kristen Bell you know
whatever a lot of people there's
something that's so stressful to me
about not knowing my lines when I'm on
set there's something so stressful to me
that maybe it's a didi maybe even this
new drug that I'm on for my ATD which
helps me maybe I could do it yeah but
there's so I'm so distracted that I you
know when I'm on set and there was like
oh we're gonna shoot it now or gonna I
just have to be so prepared yeah well
you're a hard worker you know how long
it takes to like I wish I could do that
you do it won't Smallville where you
like that even after she doesn't matter
because they always had a lot of lines
and always I try but I couldn't learn
them like it you know you and Jensen I
was talking on supernatural those guys
they don't look at it and
tons of stuff like oh yeah yeah yeah I
got yeah pretty good I get on the second
take yeah I'm so I think I'm so consumed
and worried about failing and and
everybody looking at me like I'm not
good right failure that I'm so hard on
myself that that's where that comes from
and I don't have to change that I don't
know how to change that right you don't
you know that's a great thing to know
about yourself you know by the way I
know we started late because I gave you
a tour around that I'm in no toys you
want to do some quick lightning round I
just didn't you get to everything you
know it's not about getting into
everything it's more about life like
that the moment you'll see you'll see
how these work but you know the
lightning rounds like to even want to
talk about the office I go uh not really
that's so cool
everybody talks about the office yeah
everybody knows booklet I nine Annie
Sandberg Terry Crews all these guys yeah
is there obviously you have to say the
girls are there anyone on that set that
you just like no are they all great yes
I like I know it's like on the dirt but
yes it's they're all incredible people
they really are and the authority with
Samberg and Joe I want you to come out
with me tonight
Joe you wonder this thing yeah well we
don't go out a lot because he's also a
father and you know he's got a life but
like we have here's what we did so Andy
and I have this thing every year where
we we make a bet we used to be about the
show where we're like how many
flashbacks you think they'll be this
season and that was fun for a while you
make like a over/under on it you know
you bet your money for my word like
steak dinner that's what we did our and
so we haven't done that in a while but
now past three years we've been doing
like who has the worst record the Jets
or the Niners he's San Fran's are doing
well yeah and so exactly so when I
getting to there was what there was one
season where you know the Jets were
doing it was it was who had the worst it
was after I lose who had the worst
record and the Jets got off to a great
start and then the Niners were terrible
and it looked like I was going to lose
it looks like the Jets would have the
better record and then the last half of
the season
the Jets tank and like the nighters of
this surge and the Jets and of having a
war season there for the steak dinner
that is not the case this year where
it's such a joke the bet was who has
better record and judging on dude this
year yeah oh and four and four and oh
that's our bet that's our kind of I mean
we go for a steak dinner and and and
talk about is it hard to balance like
you say you're dealing with a lot of
stress you're going to therapy in
therapy sessions what do you talk about
what will you say she'll say Joe how are
you doing and you'll say I'm stressed
out of my ass I can't stop obsessing
about this movie that isn't here I don't
know if Brooklyn nine-nine is coming
back I don't know what's going on my
wife's doing this charity work with
immigrants I look at me I'm worrying
about things that aren't that important
right I can't get it straight I I'm nude
again I nude it I'm new to therapy like
I yeah I I don't know really what to
talk about there so I get there and I
just start talking about my day and my
mood and you know issues like my issues
are like not that different like
insecurity am I being the best person I
can be you know am I giving back am i a
good husband and my good father you know
all the all these all the basic boring
[ __ ] that a lot of people and not boring
[ __ ] but you know important stuff but
there's nothing there's nothing nothing
specific there's no like specific issues
like I'm gonna talk about how great it
was to do this you are yeah and then
she's gonna like why was it great I'm
like well because I got to see my friend
Rosie I got to talk about some things I
don't talk about often I got to see his
house get to meet Ryan and then you go
from there and you know and then I'm a
little nervous about getting a camera up
my ass tomorrow a little bit nervous
about never sleep you know obviously in
fact if you I have an ambien I could put
your sleep put it out of your ass wake
you up and say hey have that feel i up
getting groceries at 2:00 a.m. and not
remembering it ambien wakes me up do you
have anything I don't do you take any
CNA or something no I am on thing you
don't take any Zoloft and he's no you
don't take it I've never been thought
about it like I should take something
it'll take the edge off I've never I'm
not a depressive person I know I know
I'm not no and I think as of late
because of the stress I'm like am I to
pret like I should look into that but
I've always been a person that's pretty
outgoing enthusiastic optimistic
annoyingly so I think sometimes you know
not eager you know but but I've always
had like an outlook of like hey man it
is what it is it's life and let's just
keep moving
I don't get too wrapped up in sadness
cuz and I'm not trying to demean that or
you mean anyone that started that that's
that's real but like that's just never
been my disposition and so if it was I
would definitely be very great pain it's
very 35 years that's a good part of it I
think so
I mean honestly if your parents were I
mean I mean look did they say Joe I love
you Joe I'm proud of you they do you
know I they have the Mets suck I mean do
they do all these things they do all
these things yes so see I think that's
vital yeah but look and again you have
to go one day in life you have to save
you a bad childhood which things happen
sure you have to say all right well I'm
my own person now I have to go over
these things yeah and I think for a long
time a lot of people like myself just
kind of yeah it's hard it's hard to go
on a sudden go all right I'm forget all
those things that happen forget not
being having this yeah so but I'm glad
I'm glad that you're honest about that
I'm glad you had a great childhood and
that shows in the person you are yeah I
mean look our family has this function
for sure but but affection was never an
issue in the in the household and
letting you know what was right or wrong
what you're proud or disappointed in is
was always very open and transparent I
think that's healthy ultimately it's
like do you feel safe right well I can't
have a kid now I'm like my job is to
love and protect this child and just
make him feel safe I feel like if you
feel safe then then you're gonna be off
you have a good start I think if you
feel safe whether you're a child or as
an adult you're gonna be the best you
can be yeah I think that if I'm not safe
whether it's on set with people who I
respect and I feel comfortable I could
try things I could take risks they're
not looking at me funny whether you feel
safe as a kid which is most vital you
have to be like hey you know even if I
drop the ball I'm not a stupid idiot I
don't suck my dad's proud or yeah those
things are so important I think being
safe it sets you up it sets you up for a
really productive life that's receptive
to everything well you know what you've
just earned yourself and inside of you
mugged I want one yep you got one on the
back of it can you read what it says it
says you should know this already
because you like you read the sides and
you get it right away should you read
that two hours ago thank you for
allowing me
to be inside of you that's right and
well rain that I want you to use it it's
a good mug it's a good-looking mug admit
it I want III do admit it and I want to
thank you for having me and I love you
brother this has been great
what's your what's your Instagram in
your Twitter I'm very Joe lo Truglio at
at Joe lo Truglio for both for Twitter
and an Instagram Brooklyn nine-nine can
be 99 is is is coming out midseason
replay
the new season season 7 will start
sometime in January and it'll be great
and funny it's january starting in other
words you shot all these we've shot
we're seven in seven out of 13 for this
season so we're we're mid see it we're
mid shooting right how many episodes
have you done total mm-hmm we've done a
hundred and thirty-eight so far at the
end of this season will be 143 so you
renegotiate it of course we did season
three was season after season six so you
wait I mean after season
yeah after season six so after season
six you've renegotiate yeah so you
waited six seasons we had to in wait
that's the contract after the second
season you negotiated you did well well
I don't think we were in a position to
now was it hard to hit show as everybody
treated equally or obviously as a saying
it was teared it was tears - yeah no
this is what we're gonna pay and you're
like was it hard
yeah but it but not really yeah works it
was it was it was paid well I I was
happy the the the women weren't paid as
well and that was wrong and and now they
are getting paid equally in the second
contract and so I think that's important
yeah it is important yeah so but again
the money the money is fine but it was
you know the money is giving me a good
life but it was really about having a
thing that I love doing going to a place
where these people we're in it together
do something funny I don't know what the
hell I'm talking oh you do know just
like look Danny I I hope Ryan just
rolled his eyes he's looking up his eyes
by the way
look Joe I hope some day I get to work
with you because I think it'd be a blast
I really love you as a human being and
as a friend and I know we haven't seen
each other in years and you know it's
it's sort of life but I'm like
this moment right here is very special
to me that's why I came I've always
liked you and I appreciate you coming
here today and I love you buddy
thank you for a lot thanks buddy
[Music]
you